first of all tully and kate's friendship
seemed so unbreakable and i think fans
are just gonna love them
but in the finale we see that they're
not even speaking what do you think
happened
that caused this rift between them we
need a season two
season two because it ends on that
cliffhanger i know
i mean what could be so big that they
literally
aren't even speaking anymore i know
because you see them go through so much
and some big stuff and they get through
it so it's got to be something big
kathy what do you think no it can't be
it cannot be that totally sleeps with
johnny
after they're married it can't be that
because i don't think any friendship
does come back from that
and this is so yeah because if you read
the book
you know the book it's in a book what
happens um
so i feel like i'm giving away but not
giving it away i don't know what to do
but anyway i'm just gonna tell you what
i think
so it can't be that because no
friendship would ever come back from
that
right has to come a friendship they have
to at some point get through this
whatever it is in the book with kate and
mara and their relationship and
obviously kate is an incredible mother
and and takes that role really seriously
and takes her relationship with her
daughter really seriously
so tully's interference in this huge way
is it for her it's up in the air right
now so i don't know what it
will actually be but i will fight tooth
and nail that it not be
that telly sleeps with johnny because
that would just
that would make me come back from that
yeah
[Music]
we see johnny he's gone off to cover the
war
and then i think we see him in some sort
of explosion
what are we meant to think is johnny
okay well i think you're meant to wonder
if he's okay
and then um i think that all things
going well
then i think that we're gonna see him
more of him and hopefully not just in
flashback
there's a lot a lot unresolved between
uh
kate and johnny as well so you know we
gotta
we gotta get get him home safe so he's
alive
i hope so i'm not writing it i'm not
writing the thing but i hope so
i hope so too um you mentioned obviously
there is a lot to figure out between
kate and johnny also in the finale we
see her go to tully and she
proclaims her love for him still
do you think that there's hope for them
i have hope for them i think you know
i don't know i don't know where what
johnny is without kate you know like he
she sort of has given meaning to his
to his life where whether previously
you know he just would have probably
drifted through life as this kind of
rolling stone and uh um you know lone
wolf so
um i think that he needs her and i
i would like to see him kind of grow up
i think he still
has some growing up to do and and get
you know get
this thing out of his system and um
and really find a deep happiness with
i would like to see him find you know
real happiness with his family and with
his wife
is there hope for tully and max or is
that kind of just
done i hope so he's such oh god john is
such an incredible actor and he was so
beautiful in that role so i'm really
hoping the first guy i told totally been
really in love with
you know for years since chad she's got
you know he can't go away oh i when i'm
watching it i'm just like
as we went we got to see some stuff and
i'm just rooting for them so much
they're so good together and
um yeah i hope so i think also what i
loved about this show is the way that
you guys handled
holy sexual harassment experience and in
that final episode we see her literally
walk away from her show because of this
network
head that has had such an impact on her
life
where do you see that storyline going
i mean kate was her producer was going
to be the producer so there's a
there's a big cliffhanger with all that
my my dream of next season would be that
the two of them
um team up and create their their like a
new show
for tully that that uh kate produces and
that there's like this great
sort of more authentic version of tully
because kate
is helping her do something even more
powerful and more meaningful
yeah i think that you know for for kate
she goes through the journey of
realizing oh i it's not my dream
i want to have kids and get married and
then
through that experience misses that side
of herself and is really bright and and
a great
writer and is doing that and then kind
of
tries to get back in the game and starts
really at the bottom and has this really
awful boss and this kind of very
negative first experience
so i think um like catherine said you
know when you when they actually if you
get kate and tully together then they'll
both be able to
thrive and kind of put their best foot
forward it'd be cool to see what they
would
what they would create together ali
there's a very hard scene
in this show involving tully
in high school and i thought it was
pretty heartbreaking
to watch and in a way that specific
scene
the rape scene carries on into tully's
adulthood
why were those stories i guess important
to tell
in your opinion i think that um
one of the main things about um this
specific scene in our show is that telly
is perceived as
you know the popular girl and and she
has everything together even if you
you know are the popular girl you know
things can still happen and then
i think it's really important to show
these storylines and talk about issues
like this
a lot more in our tvs and show people
that you know you're not alone
even if you don't feel comfortable
talking to someone you know especially
for
telly one of the main things that helps
get her through this is having kate and
having somebody to talk to and having
somebody to confide in
so i think as important as it is to
always say you know
talk to somebody tell someone how you're
feeling ask for help if you need it
three things that you would love to see
in a possible season two first of all
i'd love to see your season two
secondly i'd love to see johnny healthy
and well
and um i'd like to see a harmonious
family life
i think but then how does it make good
tv i love all the stuff when
you know when johnny goes to the front
lines of
conflict and we go to go to war so you
know i personally wouldn't mind seeing
some more of that stuff i think that
there's like so much
fun stuff to come um if if we do get a
second season i think that this season
um has dealt with you know just the tip
of the iceberg when it comes to their
70s teen shenanigans
i agree i think that there's a lot of
you know as they get older too
you know as they enter older grades and
you know start experimenting with
different things i think that there's a
lot
of different stuff that can happen and
you can dive so much deeper into it as
you've been friends for longer and you
kind of have more of a history
together i think kate should have like a
super awkward
boy encounter for sure i think next
season kate needs something happening
boys
i think yeah just more trouble i think
we need to like go on more adventures
and like
do more crazy things together feel more
cars
yeah terrorize more men
you